and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist today we're gonna talk about
simple families we're gonna talk about
minimalist parenting we'll talk about
traveling with a family and we're gonna
answer all of your questions I don't
have any kids I love talking about kids
it's so easy to give advice
Ryan is actually a really good parent
we're gonna answer all of your questions
today with our guests today Barbara hona
is here from simple families calm she
also has a great podcast called the
simple families podcast thanks for being
here today welcome so the format of this
is we we dive right into these questions
our first question today is from Brad in
Sydney Australia we have two small kids
and my wife loves buying them things
like toys crossed-up outdoor gear you
name it I mean I love it too because I
see the kids happy and they learn new
stuff because they're playing with
different toys and and so on and the
house is not a pigsty by any stretch but
how do I help her see that it's robbing
the house taking space and that they end
up like me playing with 10% of the toys
after a while anyway so what do you
think in Danae how do I force my wife to
stop buying toys for all these kids well
I know I don't know about you all but I
know that my husband listens to better
better to other people that need us to
me I think that finding an outside
resource can be really helpful I know
that when I started diving into
minimalism my husband was a little bit
hesitant and he watched the documentary
and I feel like that got him on board
hearing it from someone else
but also understanding that when you as
an individual are moving in a slightly
different direction from your spouse in
some ways it kind of violates this group
identity that you have formed if you
have changed your mindset right if you
both have been operating under this idea
that you are buying in similar ways and
you're functioning in similar ways as
soon as one person steps back it says
Wow
wait a minute should we do things
differently sometimes that can be that
can come across as a rejection of
other person and of this identity that
you have created together as a couple
so I think that it's it's normal for her
to be a little resistant or for her to
not quite understand the direction that
you're moving in because it is different
maybe then what where you've been in the
past or what you've what you've done as
a couple in the past so I think that
giving her time to come around to it
giving her other resources to introduce
her to these ideas can be really helpful
when it comes to toys one of the things
that I like to share with families is
this idea of front-loading versus
backloading toys and we all have a
tendency to want to see a lot of joy
when kids open up toys right like
there's that Christmas morning wanting
them to tear and tear into it and light
up and that is something as gift givers
that we thrive on we want to see that
right we we are just as excited about
giving the gift as they are about
opening the gift and when that is our
focus seeing that those those moments
those fleeting moments of joy in the
beginning that's that's front-loading
the joy right so there's toys such as a
lot of the plastic light-up
battery-operated toys that will make our
kids really happy and excited you know
the toys that they see in the
commercials those are the toys that are
gonna get them the most excited because
they've seen the advertisements they've
seen the YouTube videos of other kids
playing with them but the reality is
those are often the toys that are gonna
get set aside after 10 minutes 15
minutes and they never get touched again
so when we can back load the toys which
is when we're buying toys that are going
to last for years toys that are of good
quality toys that are open-ended that
can be used in multiple ways by kids of
different ages that joy on their face
when they get like this amazing high
quality set of wooden blocks it's not
going to be there right in the beginning
when you're giving them that gift but
the gift comes out over time right the
value shows itself over periods of weeks
and months and years so I think when we
can think about it like that when we're
thinking about we are giving our
children joy to last a lifetime rather
than just a few minutes it can be sort
of a mindset shift a new way of looking
at it
I think we want to be careful the the
point isn't like perpetual constant
manic excitement although we like that
in the moment when they're opening those
presents on Christmas morning you're
like you're so excited for them it's
excitement by proxy but I could just say
yesterday as a matter of fact Ella she
she was very loud and rambunctious and
and at some point you're like okay this
this is going to turn into a crash we
all we all realize like this is not
going to end up well when she is yeah
manic for hours on it because she gets
really tired and and I noticed that with
with the objects that she brings into
her life there's nothing wrong with
owning things and I think we have to
understand that we don't want to
necessarily just impose our own beliefs
on a kid because of course I'm not gonna
find value in the light-up toy or any
toy really but I also realized that they
might find or she might find value in it
so you talked about with with Brad you
talked about two things that really
stand out here one is hey it might take
some time you know Brad I don't know how
old you are but let's say you're 30
years old maybe it took you 30 years to
figure out this thing called minimalism
right and then all of a sudden we want
our significant other to figure it out
within 30 minutes and that doesn't work
very well it's it's you can't drag
someone over the finish line
because there's gonna be kicking and
screaming the whole time that's not
success that's not winning and the other
thing that you you talked about with
with respect to the kids was crap I lost
my train of thought that's really do
love the idea you're talking about how
when one partner starts to go a
different direction it's almost like you
have to respect that discomfort that the
other partner is feeling and not like
you said Josh you can't drag someone you
can't force someone to see the benefits
of minimalism all you can do is ask for
support and you know the best way to get
support is to give support so Brad if
you are supporting your wife and in many
ways just ask her for a little bit of
support here and there and and don't put
too much pressure on her but I think
that's a that's a beautiful point about
having to on
that discomfort that's going to come up
when when you start heading a different
direction that was actually my second
point was about it might even feel like
they're growing apart in the moment
right because what you're saying is it
almost feels like an attack on this
lifestyle you've built together you you
had some similar beliefs for a long
period of time but now you've received
some new information and maybe that new
information is like wow all the things I
thought we're gonna make me happy aren't
actually making me happy all the things
I thought were gonna bring great joy to
my family into my kids into my life
aren't bringing that same joy or maybe
even the things that we once got joy
from are no longer bringing us joy the
beliefs that I had are no longer my
beliefs anymore but your partner might
still have those beliefs right yeah and
actually in my own partnership this
makes me think of this year for 2019 I
gave up alcohol and for years my husband
and I haven't been together for more
than 15 years and that's kind of what we
did together right we went to college
together we drank at bars then we got
older and we drank bottles of wine at
home and it became part of what we did
it part of how we spend our time
together and so this year you were nine
for months and now I'm not drinking and
he's still drinking and I think that
that has really caused us to look at how
are we going to spend our time together
how are we gonna find a new normal and
what does that look like and one thing
is for sure that I don't want him to
think that I'm viewing him as bad or I'm
rejecting him for continuing to make the
choices that I'm no longer making so
it's finding this partnership on
slightly different paths which i think
is very possible but it's it takes some
time to work it out and figure out what
its gonna look like yeah you want to
like withhold as much judgment as
possible like you don't want your
husband to feel like well I don't drink
that means you shouldn't drink it's it's
more of yet going back to that whole
support role if you're supporting him
he's going to support you so when I
think about maybe Brad and his wife
going down a road of more intentionality
and trying to implement some some of
these principles with their children you
know they can start really small right
like maybe Brad you could offer like the
one in one out rule or the one in ten
out rule whatever your wife is willing
to agree to but finding these small
little things
incorporate that there's definitely one
little thing out there that the one in
one out rule is the first thing that
comes to mind I don't know if you guys
have any other ideas I think the toys
aren't aren't the point right yeah I
think sometimes we get really caught up
in this whether it's toys or our as
adults the our own sort of toys you know
the consumerism in general the things
are hardly ever the point
they're there to augment the experience
for kids that's then you want the Hat
then the other toys as you mentioned
that they're actually going to play with
not just discard after 10 minutes yeah
and I think with kids it's hard because
their moods are a lot more extreme than
ours so we tend to see happiness as this
extreme periods of joy where they're
laughing and giggling and then the
unhappiness is where they're screaming
and crying and a lot of times young kids
that kind of cycle back and forth
between the two I don't have this great
area that we do where we're just kind of
we just spar we're just being and so as
parents if we want we want to raise
happy kids and part of that is seeing
the joy and the laughing and the giggles
because it's harder to recognize that
that in between that just everyday sort
of gray area which can be really
beautiful but is under acknowledged yeah
I know a lot of parents to who they can
get their kids on board by really
showing how hey if you get rid of these
four toys that you don't play with
there's another unfortunate kid out
there who could use those toys who I
know you do that without like she and I
think it's about getting them so again
this takes time as well but but it's not
just going to the goodwill and dropping
the toys off it's understanding where
those toys are going that she's no
longer playing with also understanding
that she's no longer playing with them
because just like kids we cling the
stuff for way too long right we hold on
to all these things just in case and and
I think instilling that at a young age
it's actually I found I don't know if
you found this it's easier for kids to
let go in fact I've heard from some
parents I don't recommend this but some
parents like yeah just one in the room
one day and got rid of half the toys
they didn't even notice it now the
reason I don't recommend that is I think
it's a great opportunity for you to have
conversations with your kids um yeah all
of my parenting advice probably comes
from Rob Bell because he's the best
parent that
that I know and he is this great audio
book called launching Rockets and one of
the things he talks about is it is
important for you to have conversations
with your kids
important for you for your kids to ask
questions because that's really how they
learn and especially if they're asking
questions and you don't know then you
have the opportunity to learn
opportunity to learn together and as
you're letting go of some of the things
they're gonna ask you questions along
the way and sometimes they're questions
that are hard for you to confront you
never want to say well just because I
said so that's a terrible answer
I can't imagine saying that to Ryan
there's a Ryan Ryan so why'd you make
that business decision because I said so
it's a terrible way to communicate but
asking questions is ultimately how your
kids are going to grow and so sitting
down with them and saying hey I hear a
bunch of toys that you have you don't
play with getting them to ask questions
about it but you also asking them
questions is a great way for us to to
communicate and grow together as a
family
yeah absolutely Ryan and what time is it
my for.we before we move on to the
lightning round Brad I'm gonna send you
a copy of our book minimalism because
one of the things that I think is
important we talked about beliefs just
just for a moment here but we in our
book minimalism we talked about the five
sort of fundamental values in our lives
where we want to be on the same page
with our significant others I think
what's nice about Ryan's and my
relationship or my relationship with my
spouse is we have different beliefs and
I'm okay with having different beliefs
it was uncomfortable at first having
different beliefs right but we have the
same values the beliefs are a path to
get us to those same values whether it's
spiritual beliefs emotional beliefs
political beliefs religious beliefs
beliefs about material things
materialism consumerism you probably
have different beliefs from the people
in your life and that's good because
adds variety to your life life would be
really boring if everyone agreed with
you on everything
absolutely absolutely agree correct
answer but what is important is that
you're headed in the same direction
you're headed toward the same place and
that's what
respect to your values and that's what
you're going to instill in your children
so I think if you understand what your
values are then you can understand start
to understand the values of others in
particular the people closest to you
understand what their values are so as
Ryan said you can better support those
people by supporting their values not
just arguing with them because you have
different beliefs so Shawn if you could
reach out to Brad cinema audiobook
version of minimalism or if you want the
book book version or the eBook version
we'll be happy to send those to you as
well now Ryan what time is it you know
what time it is it's time for our
lightning round where we answer
questions from social media now today we
are at the minimalists on Twitter and
Instagram and Facebook and you are at
simple families on Twitter and I believe
it's at simple underscore families on
Instagram okay there but I'm not so much
there okay well you can just go to
simple families com you can find links
to all her social media but we try to
answer these questions with just a short
shareable less than 140 character
response and Shawn puts the these we
called minimal Maxim's he puts them in
the show notes so you people can copy
and share up hit the answers on social
media but sometimes we just ramble and
ramble and then Shawn just heat and post
he makes it look really beautiful with
tweezing something out yeah so we've got
some some questions here we'll try to
give some pithy answers but we'll expand
on them as well Ryan you got for us all
right first question is from kami how do
you encourage the concept of minimalism
on kids who go to school and feel
pressured to compete with the kid who
always has the new shiny toy and the
coolest clothes
well my pithy answer is intentionality
as an action is more important than
minimalism as a concept I think quite
often we stumble across something like
minimalism or a religion or an ideology
and we say well that's the goal that's
not the goal it's it's the tool right
getting rid of the excess stuff or
whatever is is making room it's not the
room itself is not the point
it's what you're going to do with the
room after that so what do you think
today you know I think kids are looking
to form an identity and they are trying
to different differentiate themselves
so one of actually had a conversation a
couple of years ago with an older
gentleman who had grown children and he
had told me that his his kids were
involved in sort of unconventional
sports so rather than putting them on
the soccer team with like thousands of
other kids that play soccer he had one
of the kids was a sea kayaker and the
other one was an indoor rock climber and
I thought that really made me think you
know what if we gave kids a path to seek
out something different and to find
their individuality in ways other than
through their stuff because we know that
they want to have this identity and how
can we help them establish that through
their experiences and through the way
that they live their life rather than
through the things that they own in the
things they wear in a less competitive
way almost sort of just setting them
setting themselves apart making
themselves unique and I think I think
one of the things that we do
unfortunately when we try to set
ourselves apart or make ourselves unique
with stuff we end up looking like
everyone else who's trying to make
themselves unique right and then we sort
of join the the club of and we have
these sort of identity markers we have
the you know the appropriate attire or
uniform that says well I am I am unique
just like everybody else that I aspire
to to live like but what is really
unique is how we spend our time through
through those actions and and the
paradox of that though is we don't want
to be utterly unique because that is
isolating right and so if a kid is is
the most unique kid in the world which
is a crazy superlative but man that
would be the most lonely experience in
the world as well yeah I love never
looked at it that way but yeah kids are
there looking to shape their identity so
we need to give them as parents you know
if you're giving them options then
they're probably gonna get more out of
that then from what the kids at school
are doing my pithy answer is this even
when you aren't teaching your child
they're learning from your actions and I
have a little aside here it's it just
says you know childhood problems often
mirror adulthood problems we kind of
alluded to that earlier in the voicemail
question but you know ask yourself what
kind of example am i setting for my kids
I always trying to get the latest and
greatest clothes am I always going out
and trying to get the latest and
greatest toys because really like Josh
alluded to also the ideology it's just
part of it like an ideology without the
example it's not going to do much for a
kid
it might even u-turn them all if you
know especially when we're constantly
saying no no no no no as opposed to
telling them what to say yes to
in fact the short the surest way to get
them to do something you don't want them
to do is to Infanta cailli tell them not
to do it is that right we have to try
really hard not to shame them for the
things that they want because I think
that that can happen very easily when we
tell them that no you're not gonna get
this you don't we don't want you to have
too much stuff having too much stuff is
bad then when they want too much stuff
they feel bad because they are sort of
going against what their parents are
telling them and what their parents are
trying to the values that the parents
are trying to instill in them too yeah
absolutely all right next question is
from Bryce in a world where children are
completely surrounded by newer bigger
better things how can parents raise
their children to focus on what really
matters in life rather than buying into
the idea that possessions equal
happiness well your we in the show so my
pithy answer is is like the cheat code
here but we tend in this show every week
with love people use things because the
opposite never works and I think
ultimately that is that's the message
that that we're trying to instill and
it's important to me that I use that
language I think language is powerful
language has the ability for for us to
tether emotions unnecessarily to
especially the objects in our life and
one thing I've been working with Ella on
is not saying I love this thing whatever
it is like I love this coffee cup or I
love this toy I love this blanket
because then you're using that same
language to describe your parents I love
you mom and I love you in this coffee
cover right and yeah when I first
started the cup first conversation was I
was talking about what her favorite
things in the house were and she had
these two stupid rocks like these were
her favorite toy
right they weren't light up they weren't
shiny they they they could break windows
if you throw them that's about all they
did and I just love these rocks and and
I had to explain to her like well you
know there that word has a certain
weight and I know we use it all the time
to describe things that we enjoy or that
we like or that we find value in or that
might be my favorite thing and that's
okay but we're giving these things a
whole lot of meaning we're imparting
meaning on these things that have only
the meaning that we give to them in the
first place we have to lead by example I
think that's the best way to instill the
values in our kids lead by example and
expect deviations from the example
because they're gonna go their own way
and they'll come back I think most of
the time I'll come back I mean kids they
gotta like try different ways and learn
lessons the hard way sometimes and as
long as we're not shaming them and we're
sending good examples yeah it should
turn out they should turn out all right
you know my pithy answer is this a loved
child is a happy child and the reason
why I wrote this down was because when I
moved in so my parents got divorced when
I was in the second grade I moved in
with my father in the fifth grade and we
didn't have a lot I mean we weren't we
were poor but he really did a good job
of being affectionate and showing me
love and yes of course I wanted like an
you know high school I liked his skates
always wanted a new skateboard I always
wanted to wear skater clothes and you
know always wanted the whatever like
there's always something that someone
had that I wanted but I will say that
not having those things I never felt
like I was lacking anything really
because I did have such a loving home
and I think when parents create that
loving home for a child like that is
that's really what is gonna give them
happiness they may not see it at the
time but I know at 37 years old I look
back and I can totally see like that is
what really gave me happiness growing up
was a loving home a few more things here
from from Rob Bell that I wrote down and
prep for this this conversation here it
really echoes what you were just saying
it's just the opposite side of this you
are only as happy as your saddest kid so
if you have multiple kids which which
Danai you yet you have a couple kids and
and there are times where one of them is
is probably acting up and you in that
moment you're as happy as your saddest
kid it it it does echo and it doesn't
have to and we can employ mindfulness
and and we can find ways especially as
parents we need to find ways above that
but but the other thing that he said
here is it is your it is a parent's job
to not exacerbate your kids this is
actually one that I struggle with I find
that I I get weird sort of sadistic joy
from irritating outlook now Ryan does
too
now he loves irritated homes small
tortures just like little tortures but
here's the thing as a parent I think
it's okay is Ryan being the sort of
uncle figure he can have fun with me the
fun uncle yeah right but what does the
thing he said about exacerbating your
your children who can your kid turn to
if the person they trust most is
irritating them and man that really
resonated with ya cuz it makes me feel
bad now but here's the thing you're not
the person that I was trust that's most
right and so she could she could turn to
her mom or she could turn to me and in
those moments and say you know Ryan is
telling me not to have fun like this is
Ryan's his his whole bit is like stop
having fun he he like forces the kid to
stop you're not allowed to have fun yeah
I don't force him but like she'll be
planned I'm like hey hey no fun and at
first it was like the look on her face
was like is he seriously now she calls
me the fun police we'll talk about that
so so there there is a dynamic between
parents right where one of you and I
think it switches from time to time but
one of you has to be a good cop bad cop
or fun police and fun parents talk a
little bit about that yeah in my house I
definitely am but I'm I'm home where I
work from home and my husband works
longer hours so I spend more time with
the kids and by default that means I am
more responsible for the day in and
you know they get dressed brush your
teeth eat lunch that sort of thing so I
think with that when you're responsible
for more of those day in and day out you
do kind of become the fun police which
means you have to disrupt the fun in
order to make the less fun things happen
but I try to be strategic about it and
one of the things that I always tell my
audience members is that we can actually
really try to pattern our days so that
our kids understand that fun stuff comes
after less fun stuff right so my kids
love to take a bath but they hate to
brush their teeth so what comes first
you know first you brush your teeth and
then you get your bath so really
starting to use that to our advantage
right not necessarily bribing or
rewarding but understanding that if we
have the less fun stuff coming first and
then the more fun stuff coming after we
can kind of keep the momentum of the day
moving a little bit more and get our
kids on board with what has to be done
rather than just kind of grinding out
all that all the stuff that they don't
want to do I love how the meth is the
reward and it's not like you get to pick
a toy to buy or you get to have a cookie
that'd be a really bad reward after
brushing your teeth but but yeah it's
important to like to choose these things
that are fun for the kids but not
necessarily you can pick the wrong
reward as room really trying to say and
we got to be careful not to do that and
what you're teaching them there is about
delayed gratification and you're
teaching them that there are small
rewards you know throughout the day it's
not always this gigantic under the
Christmas tree have to unwrap this
because that's just a poor expectation
right well if there's always a reward
I'm bribing you that's um - that's a bad
precedent yeah the rewards aren't really
rewards per se I think about the other
day my daughter was a I asked her to go
to the potty and if you ask a
two-year-old to go to the potty you're
always gonna get a no always gonna get a
no no matter if they have to go so but
you're gonna get it no so I asked her we
were getting ready to go and I said you
know it you first you have to go potty
and then we're gonna get in the car and
go and she said no and she wouldn't go
and then she walked up to me with her
doll and she said can you help me put
this dress on the doll and I said sure I
can help you first you go potty and then
I'll help you right so I'm just
capitalizing on that moment she needed
me and I needed her right so we do for
each other
I need
I really need you to go potty because
we're getting out of here and you really
need to put the dress on so you do
something for me and I'll do something
for you and sort of the creating this
back and forth of that it sort of was a
reward in the moment because it
motivated her to what do what needed to
be done but at the same time it wasn't a
tangible reward like we're so accustomed
to giving it's not like go potty and
I'll give you three raisins or something
like that right well it's interesting
because like when I think about you know
that that when you're supporting your
spouse like that's when we talk about
supporting it but with our kids we have
to find ways to support our children
because sometimes we need their support
alright it looks like we have several
more surprise questions this week how
come my parents and I cohabitate
peacefully when our values and beliefs
are diametrically opposed it's like
their parents are the villain in this
we'll talk about that don't live with
villains I mean whether they're your
parents or not you shouldn't be living
with villains we're to get to that how
can I be a minimalist when the people I
live with don't value my lifestyle how
do you manage kids toys and clothes when
you have too many and it's really hard
for the kids to give those toys away how
do you handle pressure from family
members there's a whole question in here
Ryan about well my family's pressuring
me to buy certain things and I don't
want to buy them we're going to get to
that also we have a question about
traveling with pets and Ryan we're gonna
play another round of overrated or
underrated we're gonna favorite game
we're gonna talk about New York City
we're gonna talk about iPhones we're
gonna talk about the state of Arizona
we're talking about recycling and much
more and if you want to hear all that
you can listen to this week's maximal
episode available exclusively on patreon
that's right you're currently listening
to our weekly minimal episode but each
week Ryan and I record an entirely
different long-form maximal episode on
the minimalists private podcast which
gives us the private space we need to
talk about the topics we don't usually
discuss in public plus patreon is the
best way for us to fund this podcast and
keep it a hundred percent advertisement
free when you subscribe to the
minimalist private podcast on patreon
you'll receive a personal link so that
our maximal episodes play in your
favorite podcast app you also get access
to our entire back catalog of more than
a
100 private podcast episodes find all
the details and all the good stuff
including an additional private podcast
episode every week over at the
minimalists dot-com slash support Ryan
what else you got for us this week man I
just want to encourage people to read
more and get informed because it is you
know we're coming up on election season
we've all got opinions a lot of memes
floating around and if we're just
looking at memes for our information if
we're just reading headlines we're
really doing ourselves a disservice all
the nuance absolutely and then also I've
got some voicemail comments and tips
from our listeners check them out
hi guys this is Caroline calling in from
Gaithersburg Maryland here are a few
tips for all the folks who are trying to
be minimal and their makeup consumption
and usage for example I have a dark
brown shade of eyeshadow that I use as
eyeshadow eyeliner and an eyebrow filler
it doesn't smudge it's long lasting and
no one notices that my eye or brow
liners are actually eyeshadow you can
also use lipstick for your lips and
cheeks I smudge a small line across my
cheeks the mova tinsel but for blush as
for my skincare routine I have been
struggling with acne for over 10 years
after spending literally thousands of
dollars on Forsyth face wash products I
decided enough was enough I went to my
kitchen my kitchen for some face care
solutions and now wash my face with the
warm water and sea salt solution which
has cleared my acne up tremendously I
also use a honey or aloe vera plant mask
for 15 minutes every week to hydrate my
skin just to make sure this is Ella era
directly from a plant not the gel you
use when you're sunburned totally
different and the latter is filled with
a lot of lots of toxins and chemicals
depending on where you get it so please
don't put that on your face lastly when
I do breakout I put one drop of tea tree
essential oils onto a wet reusable
cotton ball and rub it on the acne spot
this serves as a DIY acne treatment
serum that is giving me great results so
I hope this helps and shows you examples
of how minimal makeup
kero genes were possible and effective
hi my name is Lisa Benson and I'm
calling from Lausanne that I've been
thinking a lot about souvenirs when you
go on a trip lately or recently our 10
year old niece came up to visit us and
she bought something small for every
family member to show that she was
thinking of them when she was visiting
and traveling but I'm thinking of a
different way that you could show that
to a friend or family member without
having to buy them something which is
they give you something small to take
with you and give you to join or
treasure to object or whatever and you
take a picture of that that object at
some landmark or special place a moment
and you share that photo with them so
it's like a piece of them was with you
on the trip alright Joe thanks again to
Danai for joining us today make sure you
check out her website simple families
comm also her podcast is available
wherever you us in the podcast it's the
simple families podcast and real quick
for right here right now here's one
thing that's going on in the life of the
minimalists this is gonna be a fun one
Ryan we're getting really close I like
fun to 4,000 patrons on patreon oh my
goodness
they're paying for Sean's well I don't
know what he's splurging on these days
his Ferrari it's a toy Ferrari right and
whatever Jordan is probably drugs I'm
not sure what he's drugged shout : trips
trips to Arizona know what's been really
nice about patreon is is this podcast
instead of every time we walk into the
studio used to cost us money right it's
actually paying for itself now because
we refuse to do advertisers but when we
reach forth out that we reach 4,000
patrons what we're gonna do is we're
gonna have a private podcast episode
with social Jess with podcast Shawn and
Jordan know more they're gonna be behind
the microphones and we're gonna be wait
dibs on filming but but Jordans still
gonna have to edit it though
but I'll hit the record button the
record money I don't think it worked
very well if we were editing the the
video but they're gonna talk about you
know what it's like to work for the
tyrant Ryan Nicodemus
they're gonna share all of our secrets
but it's gonna be fun so once we get the
four thousand thank you to our patreon
supporters by the way this podcast 100%
amazing advertisement free so that
anyone can listen to it and we have this
beautiful studio space and we have these
beautiful people that we work with
thanks to you all you know when I was
before we started doing patreon I
donated a dollar two dollars here and
there two different two different shows
and different you know causes and stuff
and when I got a say man is like I
didn't realize I never felt like it was
much it was just kind of like a here's
my support but man I got to tell you
like being now that we do patreon like
that that $2 per episode like that means
the world to us so yes thank you to each
and every one of you that support us
really grateful for that for those of
you who can't afford it totally
understand we continue to to make these
minimal episodes for you we try to make
them as meaty as possible so you get as
much value as you can if you have a
question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast leave us a voicemail for
zero six two one nine seven eight three
nine or you can send a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists com
you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalist and if
you want our show notes in your inbox
sign up for our email list over at the
minimalists comm so uh just a
minimalistic calm no / there just go to
the website in your email address at the
top and we'll never ever send you spam
but we will send you our simple Sunday
emails each week as well just something
something we're writing about simplicity
for our added value this week let's
listen to the title track from joy
Williams new album or euphoria joy
Williams no I'm not but I thought this
said front punch do you member the civil
wars yes yeah so the group of some was
like that happy said like story about
the civil wars what do you mean like how
they started was some kind of contest or
something right yeah they did it was
like I think they were paired up via
this contest so Roy Williams jump all
white the and they had the most ice
autumn live once I think it was at
Cincinnati and it was the most beautiful
chemistry between two individual
individuals I've ever seen but let you
could tell this wasn't love this was
like something else this was passion
lust Kimmage chemistry something I
I don't know what it was but it was it
was a flame that was burning hot and it
made an amazing show made some amazing
music but joy Williams is an amazing
solo artist as well she has a new album
it's called front porch and this is the
title track from front porch check it
out and if you leave here today with one
message yeah we hope what's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for listen
y'all we'll see you next time minimus